sur ce plateau paul thompson vice
président de la section parisienne du
parti conservateur britannique
bonjour merci d'être présent avec nous
aussi
aujourd'hui il ya donc michel barnier
qui rencontre charles michel qu'est-ce
qu'il faut attendre de ce rendez-vous et
qu'est ce que vous en tant que
britannique qui représentait le parti
conservateur est ce que vous vous
attendez de ce face à face
je pense que la rencontre aujourd'hui
que vous évoquez atom une rencontre
interne aux instances de l'union
européenne donc je ne pense pas qu'il en
sortira quelque chose de spectaculaire
tout le monde savait que cette
négociation serait compliqué c'est
normal vu les intérêts en jeu et la
complexité du de la matière on a au nom
ou au début donc il n'y a rien de
surprenant à ce qu on a pu constater des
désaccords sur certaines positions de
fond rien de surprenant selon vous rien
d'alarmant non plus il va
rester au moins jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour cette période de transition
pour les négociations
on a entendu michel barnier évoqué une
problème de gouvernance notamment sur
l'accord futur il demande un cadre
global qui a priori n'est pas présent
pourquoi et comment trouver des
solutions il y à des jeux tactiques dans
toute négociation menée avec compétence
ae et chaque chaque côté ces deux
orienter les travaux d'une manière qui
lui soit tactiquement favorable par
exemple droit et munich a insisté pour
que soient exclus
ah les sujets sécurité et défense ce qui
est tactiquement intelligent parce que
le ramener à des cartes très forte à
jouer dans ce domaine et donc c'est une
sorte de gage qui est gardé en réserve
pour peser sur la suite des négociations
dans les 1 étape ultime de même là
l'idée d'un cadre global ou de d'accord
plus sectorielles n'est pas vraiment un
sujet de fond à mon avis ce qui compte
c'est le véritable substance des
résultats matière par matière et à la
question de la pêche
il y à la question d'aider des services
financiers ce sont des sujets importants
en ce qui concerne la coopération
judiciaire et policière que monsieur
barnier a évoqué dans l'extrait que vous
avez montré il y à une question de
principe très importantes portant sur la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et la hogra et munich mais il ya
eu des critiques en france aussi on
estime qu' il
cette institution a été dévoyé par un
tribunal
le qu'européen des droits de l'homme à
strasbourg qui est devenu très
idéologique et
j'ai vu le coût de tout entière elle a
décidé de façon très prévisible que
george soros n'aurait pas dû que nous
sommes universités à un boulet ps n'aura
pas dû être chassé du pays s'étaient
venant de ce tribunal
archi prévisible comme résultat et au
royaume uni il ya beaucoup de critiques
portant sur cette institution
d'une certaine façon je dirais que rien
de tout cela un fondamental qui est
fondamental c'est la volonté des parties
de conclure justement pour pour conclure
et tous et ses points de divergences
parmi l'un des points de divergence vous
l'avez évoqué il ya la pêche on sait
qu'il ya une divergence entre les
britanniques et les français il ya
quelques semaines amélie de montchanin
la secrétaire d'état française aux
affaires européennes avait dit on ne
ratifiera pas d'accord si l accord est
défavorable notamment aux pêcheurs
français
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez ce qu'il
faut garder à l'esprit c'est qu'il
s'agit des eaux territoriales
britanniques sas aide ce n'est contesté
par personne la question donc c'est qui
peut pêcher quoi dans ses eaux
territoriales britanniques
l'union européenne voudrait simplement
maintenir le statu quo ce qui n'est pas
très logique étant donné que le royaume
uni ne fait plus partie de l'union
européenne
la position de l'ue mme du dos à munich
et quand il s'agit d'une négociation
annuelle pour fixer des ddd couteau
comme pour les pays du 27 états membres
restants à un certain et c'est le cas de
la france ont des activités de pêche
importante dans ces eaux d'autres comme
l'allemagne par exemple ou la hongrie la
pologne
elles ne sont pas concernés donc je ne
pense je ne suis pas sûr que la france
puisse imposer son agenda particulier
sur cette question à tous les autres
états membres de l'union européenne
parce que les intérêts ne sont pas les
mêmes merci beaucoup parlent thompson
avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes vice-président de
la section parisienne du parti
conservateur britannique
merci à vous